[Music]
moral self-consciousness having attained
its truth that therefore abandons or
rather supersedes the internal division
which gave rise to the decembe once the
division between the in itself and the
self between pure duty qua purpose and
reality qua and nature and sense opposed
to pure purpose it is when thus returned
into itself concrete moral spirit which
in the consciousness of pure Duty does
not give itself an empty criterion to be
used against actual consciousness on the
contrary pure Duty as also the nature
opposed to it our superseded moments
spirit is in an immediate unity a self
actualizing being and the action is
immediately something concretely moral
paragraph 634 is relatively short and
we're not really seeing the word
conscience being used in this which we
would expect since it is in the title of
the section but there is some other
Hegelian terminology that plays a very
important role here that is somewhat
obscured by Miller's own translation and
I don't like to knock other people's
translations too much it's a very
difficult thing to do Hegel perhaps more
than others but in this section there's
actually some things that are being left
out a little bit and one of them occurs
at the very end of this paragraph where
Hegel tells us that spirit is in an
immediate unity he goes on the action is
immediately something concretely moral
that something is actually the word
Gestalt which means shape right and we
are talking about a new shape of
consciousness so we don't want to just
say an indiscriminate something we have
a form or shape of consciousness that is
in advance on the others no why isn't it
advanced on the others because Hegel
actually uses the term o'haven in its
verbal form right at several times in
this section he talks about the third
thing here the this this concrete moral
spirit basis which is in the
consciousness of pure duty etc etc right
and it talks about superseded moments
well the super session is alcohol banais
right so they have been they've
undergone a process on an album that has
produced a new Gestalt and a little bit
earlier in the section he also uses Alf
Haven as well where he says that yeah
moral moral self-consciousness having
attained its truth it therefore abandons
or rather to be you know using the
correct term
supercedes so here Hegel is talking
about something very important for this
section what what is it that moral
self-consciousness
has now started out trying on as a new
shape of consciousness why do we have a
new section this is the question that's
being answered and he tells us here that
we have finally figured out what the
truth of moral notice he doesn't say
moral consciousness right or the moral
point of view moral self-consciousness
and the reason I bring that up there's a
little bit of a digression but I think
this is quite important is in this
section particularly in the paragraphs
coming up soon and just a little bit
before we saw the importance of a term
that first came up in the self
consciousness section recognition on air
cannon alright and we're going to see
that playing itself out here so it's not
just moral consciousness or the moral
point of view its moral self
consciousness a moral consciousness that
takes to stand on its own consciousness
on its own fitness to duty to morality
to what it is that you know the holy
will requires whatever it is that we're
thinking about in this respect however
we formulate it so that's an important
point
let's look look at the text now Hegel
says moral self-consciousness attained
its truth right so it abandons it leaves
behind or supersedes brings along with
it the internal division which gave rise
to the decembe ones and again you know
internal division the division
you know Taitung splitting aside in zigs
ELPS and we could say that okay we've
got a internal division internal to what
well its internal to the moral
consciousness is it not that's the
important role here
of our you know phenomenological
observation as the observer we're seeing
the moral consciousness try to be moral
and end up splitting itself against
itself but all those parts are still
moral consciousness and Hegel brings up
just two of the ant enemies right
something that is in itself Anzhi right
or something that is the self is ELPS
right or something that is pure duty
picked qua purposed smack right as alts
neck or reality view click kites as a
nature and sense and we've got all these
other ways of arranging it as well but
in the first section the you know
exploration of the moral
self-consciousness
it was noting all of these things and
what we saw is is sort of a plurality
arise in what should have been a unity
the unity that we're gonna achieve now
in this current section that led quite
naturally to attempts to overcome this
and then attempts to talk it away or
pretend that it's not there a decembe
once a fish Talon and so Hegel tells us
that here we go the internal division
the division within moral consciousness
gave rise to the semblance the division
between the in itself the South we don't
have to go through all of that and then
he says when it returned into itself it
is and here he uses a term quite
deliberately concrete moral spirit Geist
okay so this is the spirit section self
consciousness is spirit spirit in a
certain sense we saw this again going
all the way back to the self
consciousness section that being
explored right even before we got to you
know the beyond the master-slave
dialectic and into stoicism skepticism
unhappy consciousness that was already
part of the issue here he talks about a
concrete moral duty right a concrete
moral spirit which in the consciousness
of pure duty
it does not give itself an empty
criterion to be used against actual
consciousness instead pure Duty winds up
being part of a moment a set of moments
rather what's the other set of moments
nature opposed to it and these are what
he calls superseded moments what does it
mean to supersede moments it means that
they're still there they're still
considerations but now they're part of a
larger unity an organic whole what is
the whole in this case is that the whole
of society no it's the whole of the
individual who has a conscience and who
acts Hegel uses the term handling here
which we can translate as Miller did as
action or we can translate it as
comportment so he goes on and he says
these are superseded moments spirit is
in an immediate unity a self actualizing
being in an immediate unity what's the
immediate unity again the individual who
is acting on the basis of conscience and
this is a form of self actualization of
making oneself veer click write the
action he says the hon Leung is
immediately something concretely moral
it is the action itself is a new Gestalt
of consciousness
suppose a case of moral action it is an
objective reality for the knowing
consciousness this qua conscience knows
it in an immediate concrete manner and
at the same time it is only as
conscience knows it
knowing is contingent insofar as it is
something other than the object but
spirit that is self certain is no longer
such a contingent knower and a producer
of thoughts divorced from reality
on the contrary since the separation of
the in itself and the self has been done
away with a case of moral action is in
the sense certainty of knowing directly
as it is in itself and it is in itself
only in the way that it is in this kind
of knowing action qua actualization is
thus the pure form of will the simple
conversion of a reality that merely is
into a reality that results from action
the conversion of the bare mode of
objective knowing that is knowing an
object into one of knowing reality as
something produced by consciousness just
as sense certainty is immediately taken
up or rather converted into the in
itself of spirit so this conversion to
is simple and unmediated a transition
effected by the pure notion without
alteration of the content the content
being determined by the interest of the
consciousness knowing it further
conscience does not split up the
circumstances of the case into a variety
of duties it does not behave as a
positive universal medium wherein the
many duties would acquire each for
itself a fixed substantial nature if it
did then either no action could take
place at all because each concrete case
involves an antithesis in general and in
a case of morality a clash of duties and
therefore by the very nature of action
one side would be injured one duty
violated or else if action did take
place there would be an actual violation
of one of the conflicting duties
conscience is rather than negative one
or absolute self which does away with
these various moral substances
it is simple action in accordance with
duty which fulfills not this
or that duty but knows and does what is
concretely right
it is therefore first of all moral
action qua action into which the
previous moral consciousness that did
not act has passed the concrete shape of
the deed may be analyzed by the
consciousness looking for distinctions
into various properties that is here in
to various moral relations and each of
these may either be asserted as
absolutely valid as it must be if it is
supposed to be duty or else compared and
tested in the simple moral action of
conscience duties are lumped together in
such a way that all these single
entities are straightaway demolished and
the sifting of them and the steadfast
certainty of conscience to ascertain
what our Duty is simply does not take
place
paragraph 635 is quite a long one and
there's a lot going on there it's really
you could say broken up into two main
sections the first part of which is
centering on what conscience is in terms
of action and then there's this this
long discussion about duties and how
they work and can we have a multiplicity
of duties in the second part of it but
these these all hold together in
providing us with a characterization of
just what conscience is at this state in
its its development and remember we're
talking about a conscience that has
emerged from all of these rather complex
dialectical reflections on morality
which itself came out of all these
reflections on culture which then also
came out of ethical life so we're at
along we're at the end of a long process
of development and this is not meant to
provide some sort of hegelian you know
description of conscience as it is in
every single person so if you're saying
well you know when I hear the still
voice of conscience within me I don't
recognize this dynamic you might not be
talking about the same thing that Hegel
has in mind at this point so let's
follow along with what he says says
let's suppose a case and and here Miller
is adding in moral action that's not
really a big problem to say so he says
you know there's an falled as honda
lands handle here is action comportment
right and he just finished talking about
this in the passage right before this so
we could read moral in here because
we're not talking about tying your shoes
we're talking about something that
conscience would be concerned with so he
says think of a case like this an action
that we would do he says it's an
objective reality for the knowing
consciousness and there you might say
all right Hegel what are what are you on
about
why bring in knowledge here isn't
conscience primarily not about
theoretical matters but about practical
matters yes but we do have to know what
it is that we ought to do and what we
ought to do it with and how things ought
to turn out and the reality that we're
working with and we could go on and on
and on so it's not so simple to
extricate those he says this the knowing
consciousness qua conscience as
conscience knows it in an immediate
concrete manner and again we've seen him
using these terms immediate and concrete
now for this is the fourth paragraph
where he's using this language what is
he doing isn't immediacy bad from a
Hegelian perspective it's always kind of
deceptive well yes but we're not at that
point yet concrete though is something
generally good what we want we we don't
want to abstract we want the concrete
universal right so he says it knows it
in an immediate concrete manner at the
same time it is only as conscience knows
it now and that is a rather big claim
isn't it what it is is known only as
conscience knows that and it not only is
only known in that way it only is in
that way as Hegel saying that unless we
cognize something it simply does not
have any being whatsoever I don't think
we should go that far with it but he is
trying to say in what matters about it
it's how we know it so he says knowing
is contingent the father gets right
insofar as it's something other than the
object what is he saying there well
insofar as my knowledge of something is
of that thing this book for example then
I could not be knowing it there's no
reason why I have to know this book or
why you do either for that matter I mean
turn the video off okay and then you're
not knowing it anymore or turn your
attention to something else it is
contingent it's dependent upon something
else but he says spirit that is self
certain is no longer such a contingent
matter when it's our own thing then we
we know what we're doing in a certain
way he's not actually like bringing up
Descartes or Augustine or the
possibility of deception here although
you know we just went through a whole
passage or actually a whole section
where we're talking about self-deception
weren't we
now conscience is convinced that it
can't be wrong about what it's actually
doing and willing and choosing so he
says spirit that self certain is no
longer such a contingent knower and a
producer of thoughts divorced from
reality why because the reality the Vere
clay kite that it's working on is what
it's producing right it's that that
there's a reality out there that then
produces our thoughts or that we produce
lots to try to match that reality we are
changing that very reality and here we
should think back to how Hegel has
treated similar processes in the past
think all the way back to the reason
section right we had reason having some
sort of direct connection to its own
activities did we not this is bearing
its fruit here in spirit in the morality
section so he says on the contrary since
the separation of the in itself and the
self has been done away with a case of
moral action is and then notice he
brings up sense
certainty the very first beginning level
of consciousness in the sense certainty
of knowing
directly as it is in itself and it is in
itself only in the way that it is
this kind of knowing why go back to
sense certainty this immediacy right why
are we circling back around at the very
end of the spirit section well let's
let's look ahead so he goes on and he
says here's what I've schematized action
qua actualization so Honda Lung
comportment action that we're choosing
qua actualization fear Clea type making
actual making veer cleek making reality
producing reality action that is that
right is of thus he says the pure form
of will what is it that we do with our
wills we we will in many different
senses of the term as many great
thinkers have pointed out and some is
you know a prime example who have
brought up at different places who talks
about the will is instrument the will as
Isis or the instances of willing uses of
the will and willing as the turning of
the will as well but that can also be
brought under lusus or that can be put
under the other category that he
recognizes towards the end the you might
call them dispositions fundamental
dispositions or aptitudes or affections
the effect she own ace of the will and
what do we mean by well well all those
different things because the will is
complex
here are Hegel tells us that we're
dealing with the pure form of will it
involves acting in such a way and
wheeling by itself is a kind of acting
by the way it is an action willing
something to be the case willing to
produce something willing to change
reality
so the me goes on today says action
quiet realization is this pure form of
will the simple conversion nice term
there the conversion of a reality that
merely is and he uses this phrase in
Zion as follows writes something that
just happens to be
the case to a reality that is the result
of action and a little bit you know
closer to the the German IANA Gotama
Vere Clea Cade
a vehicle e kite that has been deeded or
done right from tune so that's what's
going on in action we're taking reality
that is the case including ourselves and
we're making it what it is that we want
it to be what we will it to be so he
goes on and he says here we go the the
simple conversion of a reality that
merely is into a reality that results
from action the conversion of the bear
mode of objective of knowing knowing an
object into knowing reality as something
produced by consciousness in a way you
know we often picture the theoretical as
having a greater priority than the
practical but I've pointed this out many
times for Hegel the theoretical is
encompassed within or at least shot
through by the practical what it is that
we actually choose produced do that is
what allows us to know the reality that
we're in in part because it's our
reality we have we have produced it and
if we want it different than it is right
if we're not happy with what happens to
be the case we have to act we have to
choose we have to do we have to will and
that's where conscience comes in right
let me put this down for a moment think
about this conscience sees how things
are and sometimes it says okay this is
great let's keep on going the way it is
just you know keep the process moving
we'll do the same sort of actions but
sometimes conscience says no no no no
this has to change
well what's going to change it just
thinking about it having some nice
feelings or you know writing a rating a
tract tweeting about it you got to do
something now
could be doing something for some people
but generally you actually have to put
some figurative boots on the ground
don't you including your own boots so he
goes on and he says just as sense
certainty has immediately taken up or
rather converted into the in itself of
spirit remember what happened way back
in sin certainty so this conversion is
simple and unmediated the transition
effected by the pure notion the pure bkf
without altering alteration of the
content what is the content the content
the in halt is determined by the
interest of the consciousness knowing it
now what does he mean by interest here
it is about being interested in or
curious about or caring about but it's
those things because it's interest in
the sense of when we talk about one's
own interest or self interest right it
doesn't have to be selfish but certainly
conscience is being motivated by its
thinking that something really is for it
it's something that's its responsibility
or its duty so he goes on and he says
conscience this is where we get to the
duty stuff does not split up the
circumstances of the case into a variety
of duties as we saw discussed in earlier
sections it does not behave as a
positive universal medium right a sort
of thing that everything else is
floating around in where the many duties
would acquire a fixed substantial nature
and he says why not why can't we have
them this many duties going on if it did
then we would have a problem either no
action could take place at all because
each concrete case involves an
antithesis in general and in the case of
morality a clash of duties we saw that
when we when we posed multiple duties
they wind up clashing with each other
and you know not just in a sort of
abstract theoretical way live a real
life and you find out that your many
duties often do clash with each other
right can't go to your kids recital and
do your job really well at the same time
there's you know one example right there
and conscience would convict you in that
case right so he says therefore by the
very nature of action one side would be
injured one duty violated and then duty
would be you know in a certain sense not
duty right or else he says if action did
take place there would be an actual
violation of one of the conflicting
duties so here he says conscience is
rather than negative one or absolute
self which does away with these various
moral substances it does not treat them
as substances it treats them rather as
moments of itself a higher unity right
but a negative unity so he says it is
simple action in accordance with duty
which fulfills not this or that Duty but
knows and does what is concretely right
sort of threads the needle figuring out
what the right thing is to do now this
is very optimistic at this point I
should point out he says it is therefore
first of all moral action as action into
which the previous moral consciousness
that did not act why did it not act
because it couldn't fulfill all these
duties there's a clash between pure duty
and the many duties
there's clashes of the duties themselves
when it's a concrete being it's able to
act so he says the pre of the concrete
shape of the deed may be analyzed by the
consciousness looking for distinctions
into various properties here into
various moral relations and each of
these may either be asserted as
absolutely valid as it must be if it's
supposed to be a duty or else compared
and tested put into a kind of listing of
a hierarchy or set of priorities or an
ensign means connection a teleological
schema conscience in this case is what
decides what counts as full duty so it's
not that there's duty and then you know
duty compels conscience rather
conscience is the thing that's actually
deciding here so
as that here we go in the simple moral
action of conscience duties are lumped
together in such a way that all of these
simple entities are straightaway
demolished and the sifting of them in
the steadfast certainty of consciousness
to ascertain what Duty is simply does
not take place so at first Hagel is
talking as if well conscience is going
to take all this information in and kind
of you know prioritize it and think
about it know it's immediate remember
right he's said this already it's
concrete and immediate and it's going to
decide what needs to be done in order to
bring about something and in a certain
way he is not saying this here but this
is something important to keep in mind
in its agency it's leaving something out
isn't it now what that is we'll talk
about that in a bit but keep that in the
back of your mind
you